[Musique]
après une large concertation durant cinq
mois le conseil départemental définit
son programme d'insertion ou pda pour la
période 2000 22 2024 l'ambition est de
prolonger au moins une mesure
d'insertion à chaque bénéficiaire dans
une logique d'accompagnement global vers
un emploi durable
cette ambition s'est concrétisée avec
cinq types d'accompagnement proposées
dans le pays cinq étapes principales
d'un parcours d'insertion
l'accompagnement global trade
simultanément les problématiques
sociales et l'accès à l'emploi dix sept
binômes composés d'un conseiller de pôle
emploi et d'un travailleur social du
département ont été déployés le pays
projette de doubler le nombre de
bénéficiaires de ce dispositif d'ici
2024 le dispositif de l'accompagnement
global a été mis en place à la réunion
en octobre 2018 suite à la signature
d'une convention entre les départements
et le pôle emploi tout ce qui est partie
recherche d'emploi accès à l'emploi en
formation etc ce travail avec le
conseiller du pôle emploi et la partie
social la levée des freins en fait ce
qu'on appelle des freins périphériques
et travaillait que le travailleur social
les freins périphériques c'est tout ce
qu'ils aient accès au logement accès au
droit ça peut être un problème de garde
d'enfants il peut y avoir des
difficultés administratives et
juridiques
entre autres un et puis surtout un
problème récurrent la mobilité et le
pôle emploi c'est on travaille en
étroite collaboration avec notre binôme
c'est à dire que nous faisons des points
mensuel mais aussi tout au long de
l'accompagnement
le pecs parcours emploi compétences vers
l'insertion dans les activités d'utilité
sociale notamment dans le domaine de
l'environnement le pays projette de
multiplier par deux le nombre d'emplois
aidés dans le secteur non marchand d'ici
à 2024 jeffrey en est bénéficiaire j'ai
fait trois ans de comptabilité
j'ai su que ça me plaisait pas et après
ben j'ai su que j'étais mieux sur le
terrain à l'extérieur que dans un bureau
je dis pas enfermés mais voilà quoi j'ai
postulé sur le pôle emploi lutte
antivectorielle et du coup ben j'ai été
acceptée points contre apec avec le thé
pays on nous accompagnent de mon image à
trouver une formation à nouveau pc a
rebondi en appel sarre ont bondi à sur
autre chose à la fin de mon contrat
j'ai commencé la formation
en tant qu elle a goûté au cfppa du
piton saint leu à grandfonds bella je me
retrouve ici avec le spl en stage mais
c'est mon deuxième stage a vécu ça se
passe super bien et où je vais mettre
des stalles d'ailleurs le maître de
stage il est là haut c'est un truc très
intéressant
moi je me sens bien dans la raba tout
rendre service aux gens que ce soit chez
les particuliers au vote
[Musique]
en fin de formation je serai amené à
travailler avec espn pour plus tard
kerry a beaucoup d'expérience peut-être
même partiront mais trop tôt le présente
plus de bagages et revenir à et ouvrir
mon propre ma propre boîte et continue à
grandir le truc
la formation le y projette d'orienter
plus fortement les bénéficiaires du rsa
vers les métiers en tension notamment
dans le secteur des services à la
personne
ceci afin de valoriser leurs compétences
sur le marché du travail avant j'étais
au rsa donc j'ai été contacté par la
directrice de lire cette qui m'a proposé
la formation avaient des âges dans cette
formation on apprend à accompagner les
personnes âgées et les personnes en
situation de handicap on apprend aussi à
faire les soins ce qui est nouveau
contre cette formation est restée chez
sont pour moi on passe de la partie
théorique à la pratique dans un
appartement pédagogique avec tout le
matériel nécessaire qu'on peut trouver
chez les bénéficiaires le centre de
formation est très bien il y a de
l'espace il y a de bon matériel
l'équipe de direction est très
accueillant les bénéfices pour moi c'est
d'avoir un diplôme reconnu et d'avoir un
emploi stable
la création d'activités comme moyen de
façonner son propre emploi le y
renforcera l'accompagnement déjà
déployés dans le cadre du r plus pour
favoriser la création d'entreprises par
les bénéficiaires du rsa comme
marie-france line
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir été formé dans
de très belles écoles
l'une à paris et l'autre dans le vercors
un temps que soins en thérapie
traditionnelle et chinois et
traditionnel aïoli dick d'une
connaissance de ce dispositif r plus
lors de mes recherches sur internet pour
le financement de ma dernière formation
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir rencontré
un conseiller qui m'a orienté ce
dispositif et à partir de là on a monté
notre notre dossier et tout s'est fait
naturellement le dispositif a plus et
une allocation qui compense la perte des
minima sociaux elle est calculée en
fonction de mes revenus d'activité
c'est une allocation qui prend en charge
50 % de mon de mon revenu du revenu de
mon activité
c'est à dire que plus mon chiffre
d'affaires augmente plus la compagnon de
la location car plus augmentent
également
l'insertion dans l'entreprise le pays
prévoit de renforcer le partenariat avec
les entreprises en multipliant par trois
le nombre de contrats aidés dans le
secteur marchand et en faisant mieux
connaître le r plus quand j'ai tombé
londres avec que pôle emploi mon dieu
pouvait bénéficier du est à + 6 mai dans
plus pour s'en sortir le mieux pour
avoir plus de pouvoir d'achat avoir
laissé
de proximité de faire plaisir un peu
plus quand vous avez un contrat cdd cdi
si vous avez un certain âge certain
un montant minimum
de vote en plein baby en bénéficier je
ressens 351 de merveilles comme ça
m'aide beaucoup et invite les jeux les
sens et
il ya beaucoup de jaloux passe à côté et
ne savent pas info il passe à côté du
belle opportunité non c'est pas l'avenir
mon sera ouvert mais
mieux
le pbi prolonge des dynamiques déjà en
oeuvre depuis 2020 il complète ses
dynamiques avec de nouvelles mesures
pour aller vers les bénéficiaires du rsa
en particulier dans le domaine de
l'accès au droit et aux logements de
l'accompagnement social et de la lutte
contre l'illettrisme